hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the unfair
platformer okay you guys have been
suggesting a few more rage games than I
should plays but I must warn you I am
totally calm right now I could not be
more level-headed and cool right now so
let's give this a try okay
you see arrow keys or WASD to move and
jump okay do I want to go to sunshine
Mountain or doom Mountain you know what
because I like a challenge
let's go to do mountain I want to I want
to give myself the right challenge these
message boxes always tell the truth
unless that is a lie well that yeah it
doesn't bother me let me see you a.m.
what's over it's subtitling yeah yeah
that's what I thought okay I like that
music okay so there's a block up there
or I'm not even supposed to go up there
nevermind
there's not a block up there Wow no were
you son-of it don't start with me I
don't want any part of that all right so
I just need to drop down here so that I
can go over here oh is it I was he
actually told the truth I can't believe
it okay
sorry it jump down here jump over here
that's a trap so I was a second one all
right then off to a good start lost six
lives already and that music is actually
getting is going to be annoying after a
while isn't it so I'm turning the volume
down on my head fed so I don't have to
listen to that well it mocks me
incessantly upon my own demise hoop huh
also this game has trapped ah ah well it
didn't lie
it did not lie so let's just keep going
forward now down and up and over and two
more and then don't go above that
two blue flags your check points yeah
yeah this is kind of built similar yeah
this is built really similarly the
unfair Mario if that's gonna be the case
you stupid son of a gun okay what the
why is that there ah no what the hell
stop it let me give a chance to serve
awk come on give me a chance to survive
here stop
doing that yeah there we go okay so I
need it Wow well wait
oh god god damn it stop it I'm trying to
survive here okay I need to jump from
here top fudge okay come on just jump
over it from here to there
no no oh Oh pop son of a [ __ ] stop it
hang on wait no hang on hang on I got
this no I can't even get to that anyway
so I just gotta jump over to huh come on
this'll stupid don't be like that don't
be like that don't be like that jump
over da ha ha ha
ah this game is after a bad no oh come
on how many wouldn't be able to get past
there this doesn't even make any sense
it doesn't make any sense at all that
make any sense at all OOP I did
leprechaun you scoop yeah yeah yeah
little flag the end of the level
yes yeah level one done level one gunnin
only like 15 deaths man I'm good okay so
I okay alright there we go okay how am I
supposed to get from oh oh that's what
up dude you son of a [ __ ] stop it stop
I let me get all thank you thank you
thank you very much for being nice and
cut stop come on don't be like that
and be good to me I'll live it ah come
on a muggy nutter aha are you trololo
lon okay the Dare it's full it's a troll
that's a trap ha ha ha such a peck
yeah shower change I'm going to I'm
going to strangle a monkey go strangle
someone
oh come on ha ha ha
yeah I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get
this son of a [ __ ] and gonna dog come
on
how much will even jump over that wait
oh ouch forgot oh okay
just take it down a notch give me a
moment to rest my weary head okay so
that's uh how I gonna be able to get
over that because it doesn't ah ah how
many that are you able to get over that
because he doesn't let me another I
don't have enough time
doesn't make any gras oh stop stop it
stop it stop it
Albert Tom hat go over there we go ah oh
I don't have to touch it that's what ha
ha I just can't touch it that's all I
got I just can't touch it and I'll be
fine I'll be fine just can't touch it
Judah who patrol super jumpy you'll be
one of these is a trap one of these is a
trap I know this ok I got that one done
I get the first bite damage Oh why space
is not jump space it Ruth ah bad ok
there we hurt calm calm cool and
collected is too early to be screaming
like this whoop-de-doo
for all day would oh yeah alright
and it was just character anyway I
haven't criticizes the main character
yet some raggedy
cerebus oh this is not fair Corson would
be called the unfair platformer hoopty
swamp ado nerdy ingo touch me okay so
the top one and the third one of the
second one from the bottom is a trick is
this one a trick they're all tricks
except for oh man oh man oh man I'm
gonna be here forever this is how I die
this is how I die just police will come
in fine a local youtuber occupier found
dead in his apartment once again
watching this girl move her butt cheeks
to the betta Beethoven House it's a
terrible sight we're so embarrass is the
second time we've seen someone succumb
to that video
maybe that video was like the ring of
butt cheek symphonies in and that
suddenly seven days later I die
maybe there's something I'm supposed to
do with that and there please oh they're
all Trixie's they're all tricked eight
maybe the bottom was is it I keep saying
like why don't I just jump as far as I
can why didn't I just do that from the
start
huh why didn't I do that huh why cuz I'm
dumb oh yeah come on I don't want to
play anymore
I don't want to play ah man I don't want
it ah come on once I get better at the
deaths come farther apart but then I get
careless and I just die from the same
stupid things I've died to before and
it's not a happy fun times how do I get
past this just jump as far as I I didn't
hop right out I push the jump button hey
young Detroit they could jump it I'm
trying to be patient here but it's not
working out I'm about to start speaking
Dutch chicken and no one wants me to
speak Dutch
yumping talking oh girl oh my life
my life is in sha ha ha how do you beat
it it has to do with that platform at
the bottom I know I know I know this is
true I know for I know for certain this
is true it has to do with something
about that platform at the bottom my
guess
wait wait I got it I got it I got it
how did that happen oh that happened
I've never done that before
I didn't even intend to go forward there
I'm gonna okay so this is my guess
sketchy Condon Coogan huh gasp learn and
I'm freakin Dutch you're hauling for it
Abbott speaking Dutch for all my life
enough my life is a lie my life is a aah
I like sweating profusely
oh come on just just drop in the hole
just drop in the hole yes yeah I play no
more oh look coins oh boy oh boy oh boy
coins whoopty where's the trick here
what's up
was that it really that was it why oh
man suiciders jump okay I'll take that
one uh-uh-uh
you can bounce you can bounce off
enemies heads I don't think so
oh but you don't want to I guess those
signs really don't tell a lie I'm gonna
wait for that guy to get over here so we
can bounce up over it which probably
will still kill me how is he oMG oh it's
not high enough are you getting bigger
wait a minute bro what bro were you
getting bigger
what do you mean that didn't me but what
what girl I didn't even make any sense
he was getting bigger though so
boring oh I get it
the more I jump on him ah there we go
I jumped on him into the aah oh look at
all the coins look oh man it takes me
forever to get from one point to another
keep yumping on him
I am pon you I jump on you there we go
okay so I need to not fall down at all
Wow well um well you come from
do you come for a Mother Russia lon you
come for a Mother Russia
y'all should know that the angrier I get
the more my accent travels the world so
where did you where did you come from
heard you son of a [ __ ] okay ah how am
I supposed to be able to know
oh I'm not to be able to know what screw
you then screw everyone you care about
screw you screw you okay so the second
toe also the third one or fifth or
whatever number you want to call it it
doesn't even matter anymore
I'm just gonna die over and over and
over and over again so the first two are
okay the next three are not next four
are not how the hell am I supposed to
get all on oh I'm not supposed to go
down there I'm going to hit the bump and
go up and go oh it's all trip don't go
over the coins that's it ah okay that
was new at least I saw something new so
congratulation guys you all something
them new a unique way to die from a
monster that you haven't seen before and
I'm going up here now and I'm gonna hit
the block I'm gonna go up and walking
cool I can't go up
I can go okay go okay go up oh yeah oh
they're so bad why good net cheerful
music that's stupid
cheerful of a deck okay BAE go there was
some Mouse bumping that bumping into
something huh there yeah there's some
here wait a minute oh oh oh wait hang on
hang on there's some there some there I
know this I know this
for I am a scheming genius
hang on watch this is something about
this well then where's the other ones
that I need to climb on I don't know
where's the other one oh faith walk with
inevitable to the poem yeah that was
totally fair hahaha who's getting good
at this game
this guy all right mister wait whoa whoa
I don't want to pull the lever I don't
want to pull that lever
aw come on it's not off oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
hey go okay go go go go go go go don't
go don't go don't go there's one air
Trixie's Trixie's /
yeah who got it ah who didn't get it
okay come on come on come on come on
come on okay so those those are rotating
blocks of arrow shooting madness okay
this is not cool yeah I'm good it is so
cloud I'll no gloves okay oh yeah I need
to stop I need to stop playing for a
minute good okay all right that'll do
for now I played this I'm getting better
at it I'm getting but I'm sweating a
little twenty it's like air-conditioned
full blast in my house but I'm sweating
so yeah oh man okay so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos thing I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
I love
ah
love
you